[Musica]
allora quando mi hanno invitata a
parlare qui oggi come speaker ho preso
qualche secondo per metabolizzare la
cosa e poi mi sono detta cacchio però
forse anche l'italia o in qualche parte
recondita del nostro paese qualcosa
qualcosa si sta muovendo qualcosa sta
cambiando
e voi direte ma in che senso ma questa
festa di oggi sono convinta che volti
molti di voi non mi conoscano come sono
convinta che qualcuno di voi chiami
conosca e quindi perché sono comunque
stata informata del fatto che avrei
avuto a che fare con il pubblico
abbastanza eterogeneo e quindi per
competenza per competenza mi presento mi
chiamo alessia mocci ho 33 anni meglio
nota come suu kyi sul al pubblico sono
nate l'abruzzo ma sono ho vissuto in
varie parti del mondo e faccio la sex
worker e che cos'è la sex worker lo
chiedo e lo chiedo a voi che cos'è una
sex worker
[Musica]
ok mettiamola così potrebbe essere una
definizione perché è una una parola che
ha tante definizioni però secondo me
nella mente di qualcuno di voi che
magari il più timido ha ritenuto
opportuno non dirlo ad alta voce sarà
balenata qualche parola come ad esempio
buttano favorite ma sta è salita sul
palco oggi a dirci ciao mi chiamo alex e
faccia la ma non è normale se è
normale lo stabiliremo dopo però intanto
vorrei definire meglio la parola per chi
mastica un pochino inglese non sarà
difficile da sex worker derivare al
termine sex worker e tradurlo in
qualcosa come lavoro sessuale
questo termine nasce negli anni 70 e si
sviluppi diffondere la lingua
anglosassone soprattutto in concomitanza
con il proliferare dei movimenti in
difesa dei diritti delle sex worker e
come avrete già intuito è un termine che
si sveste della pagina stigmatizzante
moralistica e denigrante che invece
riveste caratterizzare il termine
prostituti prostituzione ed è per questo
che comincia a diffondersi di recente
anche nella lingua italiana
ci sono due tipi di sex working o di sex
worker il sex worker diretto comunque lo
vediamo appunto alla prostituzione di
strada
l'escort in accordi fra privati o la
prostituzione doorway windows
quella che abbiamo amsterdam dove le
prostitute sono in vetrina e il sex
worker in diretta tra cui troviamo il
bondage la dominazione lap dancing
stripping ed è proprio tra questa in
questa ultima categoria proprio tra
quelli che a cui piace
farsi calpestare farci fare pipì addosso
che si inserisce anche la ne figura che
proprio in questa categoria che noi
inseriamo anche l'industria della
pornografia e tutta quella parte di
persone che lavorano sul web vendendo
contenuti sessuali o erotici ori nudo su
siti di monetizzazione o comunque
facendo web cam cam webcam modeling
abbiamo quindi capito che è propriamente
il termine sex worker è sinonimo di
prostituta tana tutte
quelle parole che purtroppo attualmente
rivestono più una connotazione negativa
vengono più usati usate come offese per
chi le riceve tante delle volte neanche
hanno effettivamente a che fare con la
vita sessuale di chi li riceve io che
attualmente o più di 4 milioni di
follower se metto insieme tutte le mie
pagine social per il lavoro che faccio
ricevo insulti di questo tipo per lo
meno 100 200 mila volte al giorno di
media
tuttavia non è quello che mi offende
anzi non mi offende ha fatto quello che
mi ferisce più spesso e quando mi sento
dire che io le mie colleghe i miei
colleghi portiamo sul web dei contenuti
che non sono contenuti e che comunque il
nostro lavoro sia un lavoro
ecco il mio scopo qui oggi è quello di
farvi empatizzare con una figura come la
mia darvi una visione più umana di
quello che noi facciamo anche
raccontandovi degli stralci della mia
esperienza e mettervi a conoscenza farvi
conoscere quello che effettivamente un
lavoro con i suoi contratti le sue
regole e le sue incombenze fiscali e
soprattutto la sua dignità mi mi
addentro in questo discorso ponendo per
un'altra domanda
pensate a tutto quello che ci è successo
da inizio 2020 a fine 2020 fino ad oggi
perché ancora va avanti
cosa quale sa qual è la prima parola che
mi viene in mente la prima cosa che
viene in mente se io vi chiedessi cosa
vi è mancato di più in questo periodo
risposte potrebbero essere tante
però sicuramente quella che ci mette
tutti d'accordo è né una e del tema di
oggi il contatto ci è mancato il
contatto contatto fisico il contatto
umano
siamo stati costretti per più di un anno
all'isolamento quasi forzato e per molti
di noi questo isolamento si è tradotto
in solitudine perché è importante dire
che isolamento e solitudine sono più
concetti totalmente differenti una
persona può essere isolata dal resto del
mondo e non sentirsi sola o può essere
buttata in mezzo a tanta gente e
comunque sentirsi sola ed è proprio
brutto constatato è successo a noi è
proprio il fatto che per molti di noi
la condizione che abbiamo vissuto si sia
trasformata in solitudine e questa
condizione questa solitudine andata a
impattare su molti degli aspetti
fondamentali della nostra vita tra cui
uno importantissimo che è quello della
sessualità
molte coppie sono state costrette a
vivere un vivere forzatamente altre
coppe sono state costrette a a staccarsi
improvvisamente i single i single hanno
visto svanire tutte le opportunità di
avere occasioni per conoscere un nuovo
partner oppure frequentazioni
occasionali semplicemente e voi direte
va bene le coppie che
che hanno vissuto insieme avranno
scopato come con in realtà
in realtà no perchè questo magari e
basso per il primo periodo la quarantena
poi a lungo andare è successo che stare
sempre insieme lo stress i soldi
finiscono il lavoro non c'è le bollette
aumentano i bambini sempre tra le
scatole finiscono le cose interessanti
da dirsi e aumentano le situazioni di
conflitto e quindi ci si allontana da
un'attività sessuale costante normale
regolare
voi direte che per me non è bassa la
stessa cosa però c'è sempre l'eccezione
che conferma la regola
torniamo seri e pur sì che è vero che la
sessualità aspetto importantissimo per
un uomo è indice della della qualità di
vita anche come abbiamo sentito prima di
altri discorsi ed è fondamentale come
quasi come l'espletamento di queste sì
fabbisogno normale umano come quello del
cibarsi e quindi in questa situazione
cosa è successo
lo dico io è successo che nella nostra
vita è entrato ancor più più
massicciamente rispetto a prima il porno
ed è pur vero che l'italia era già al
settimo posto della classifica mondiale
dei paesi da cui si genera più traffico
dei siti porno più famosi come ad
esempio pornhub ma c'è una cosa e poi
non facciamo i bigotti a chi a chi non
piace il porno a tutti piace il porno
adulti adolescenti dopo neanche le donne
invece il con a me piace tantissimo il
forno però non vorrei offendere qualcuno
perché magari c'è anche chi dice no io
mai visto mai usato allora procedo per
assurdo e ipotizzo per assurdo che a
tutti piace il porno ma c'è una cosa che
fece ancora di più alle persone e vc
porto con qualche esempio
immaginatevi che il porno a fare porno
non sia più una modella perfetta
patinata irraggiungibile che non potete
toccare lì sul vostro laptop sullo
schermo della nostra televisione ma che
sia una persona più vicino a voi vicina
alla migliore amica o il fruttivendolo
sexy sotto casa quello che vende le
banane o una cantante una cantante che
totalmente staccata da un ambito
prettamente sessuale di cui amate la
musica ma mi sei sempre chiesti ma
questa come sarà nuda come come si
comporterà a letto oppure vi faccio un
altro esempio
questa è la foto con cui sono andata
virale quattro anni fa sul web
no proprio praticamente sotto casa
il supermercato vicino casa davanti a
patatine
una tuta bruttissima all ascella pezzata
perché se non l'avete notato
c'è anche l'ascella pezzata poi
ovviamente quello che ti è piaciuto di
più e questa cosa questa roba qui in
mezzo a un milione di di altre foto
qualitativamente superiori di ragazza
più bella e più alte più fatte da
fotografi in mezzo altre foto mie sui
rami cui ero più più nuda più tutto
questa roba qui mi ha fatto fare quattro
in meno di quattro mesi più di un
milione di followers
quindi resta quello che piace la gente è
una normalità e avere un espiare nella
vita delle persone più vicine a noi e
quindi un approccio più concreto più
diretto di quello che può essere il
porno standard e questo meccanismo
psicologico alla base di quella che è
stata la fortuna di un sito che in
pandemia in concomitanza con gli altri
siti porno ha avuto un buon pazzesco
magari qualcuno di voi lo ha già sentito
nominare
questo sito si chiama only fans ed è
comunemente definito come un sito di
divulgazione di materiale pornografico
amatoriale ma in realtà questa una
definizione molto parziale e quindi
imprecisa prettamente all i fans è un
sito che offre la possibilità a
qualsiasi tipo di creator di poter
monetizzare sulla prova fanbase quindi
offrendo pacchetti mensili di iscrizione
i propri fan che pagano questa film
mensile e accedono ai contenuti premium
del creator che preferiscono quelli
spiegato al cuore ad essere di qualsiasi
tipo
un cantante uno scrittore un pittore un
professore radiatore un personal trainer
qualsiasi è anche vero però che el 80
per cento degli introiti di questo sito
è dato di aprile per con me che fanno
contenuti sessuali erotici nudo e quindi
nella definizione generale del sito si
tende a escludere l'altra fetta
e anche vero quello del mio discorso non
ci interessa proprio l'altro felice io
oggi sono una delle creator che le sexy
creator italiane più seguite al mondo su
questo sito
riguardo mi ricordo mia nonna quando ero
piccola mi ripeteva sempre una stessa
cosa con stessa frase mi diceva alessia
ricorda una cosa gli uomini nella vita
devono nascere crescere quindi mangiare
riprodursi quindi scopare e morire non
me lo diceva poco si sa va modi più un
po più colorati però meno male diceva se
tu nella vita
fai un lavoro che riguardi questi
aspetti non ti mancherà mai il pane
sotto i denti e quando più di quello che
ci è successo durante questo periodo
dimostra quanto lei avesse ragione e
quando più lo dimostra in ambito
sessuale
quindi alla luce di questo perché noi ci
meravigliamo se un sito come li fans
molti si vergognano anche una vergogna
con un sacco di gente sentito come le
fans abbia avuto un boom così forte in
un momento in cui c'è manca totalmente
il contatto
il contatto con gli altri e quindi anche
la nostra sessualità andate in crisi
perché ci meravigliamo se questo sito ho
passato avere una base di iscritti di
200mila persone inizio pandemia
per finire con più di 150 milioni di
persone sopra a ritmi di crescita anche
di 500 mila persone al giorno perché ci
meravigliamo non c'è da meravigliarsi ve
lo dico io non c'è neanche da
vergognarsi perché è pur normale che se
c'è una domanda a cui si forte sul
mercato ci sia una una risposta ci sia
un'offerta e quindi e pur normale che ci
siano persone che scelgono di fare il
lavoro che faccio io e scelgono di farlo
in qualsiasi modo preferiscano perché se
c'è un sito che permette di farlo perché
no possiamo ritrovarci personal trainer
prendono i video dei loro allenamenti
tutti nudi o la quota che vi insegna a
fare la p campari nuda
ci sono persone che lo fanno
semplicemente per tirare avanti e
arrivare alla fine del mese
conosco ragazze che lo hanno fatto per
pagarsi la retta dell'università
durante la pandemia in un periodo che
comunque ha tolto il pane dalla bocca di
quasi tutti e mi sento ancora dire
nonostante questo nonostante io credo
che sia normale che la prostituzione
tutte le sue sfumature realtà mercifica
il corpo delle persone il corpo delle
donne soprattutto e arrivando vorrei
citare uno degli stand up comedian che
io amo di più che giorgio montanini che
in un suo famosissimo monologo
intitolato elogio alla prostituzione si
rivolge al proprio pubblico dicendo ma
non fate moralisti non fate le finte
picot è finta femministe che dicono che
la prostituzione
la mercificazione e lo sfruttamento del
corpo della donna che dicono che
medievale perché i lavoratori di
fincantieri oi tuoi meccanici non
sfruttano sfruttano il loro corpo
polmoni cartilagini schiena
il problema qui non è che si tratti
dello sfruttamento del corpo che si
tratti dello sfruttamento di determinate
parti del corpo che non sono cartilagine
ginocchia e schiena ma sono altre parti
del corpo che ben conosciamo perché io
quando lavoravo al bar ho fatto 15 anni
di bar lavorato come bar tender per una
vita facevo degli orari incredibili
dalle quattro di pomeriggio le cd
mattina si spaccava la schiena può che
fare con persone ubriache molto spesso
perché lo ascoltavo il mio corpo
quindi per me è assurdo sentirmi
dell'infezione simili e sarebbe bello se
tutti i ragazzi le donne e gli uomini
che scelgono di fare il mio lavoro
smettessero di essere così tanto straci
dati o condannati o subire gli immediati
che quelle che subiscono ogni giorno
sarebbe bello che potessero farlo nella
tranquillità nella normalità della
scelta di un lavoro normale sarebbe
bello che io non ricevessi più commenti
come questo sotto i miei post di
continuo
e però mi sentissi più dire che io mi
devo vergognare che mia madre si deve
vergognare che non può non ho il diritto
di essere madre perché probabilmente mia
figlia si vergognerà di me lo sarà
grande
avevano detto che non avrei neanche
trovato un uomo che mi avrebbe amato per
tutta la vita avrebbe deciso di
condividere la sua vita con me
e invece proprio grazie al mio lavoro un
lavoro normalissimo che ho conosciuto
figlia un uomo che miri a ma mi rispetta
rispetto al mio lavoro al controllo del
mio ex marito che nonostante non vedersi
le mie foto nuda sul web allora va
rispettata e mi ha tradita malissimo e
grazie al mio lavoro un lavoro
normalissimo che ho potuto ripagare i
vigili in questi ultimi anni di tutti
gli sforzi che hanno fatto nella loro
vita una vita da operaio in fabbrica per
assicurarli tutto quello che mi servisse
i miei studi per non farmi mancare
niente e grazie al mio lavoro se posso
avere una vita normale con un lavoro
normale e avere degli obiettivi a cui
tutti quanti
normalmente andiamo perché sex worker
his work e probabilmente se io non
avessi avuto il mio lavoro che non
avessi avuto la forza in questi ultimi 4
5 anni di ignorare tutto quello che mi
veniva detto di continuo viene ancora
detto che continuo di scegliere per me
di scegliere cosa è giusto per me e non
quello che gli altri
spero di farvi credere
probabilmente non avrei nulla di tutto
quello di cui oggi sono fiera di cui
probabilmente mia nonna sarebbe fiera
anche la cosa più bella e più normale
che ci sia come questa
[Applauso]